you know what you know what no idea to
me
hi I'm Brooke and we've been dating for
three years yeah hi my name is Rita and
we've been dating for three years
[Music]
because it was off and on so much the
beginning yeah I'm nervous about playing
this game because you're not sure what
I'm gonna say I'm excited because I want
to see what she has to say and I haven't
heard these questions or anything before
so I want to know when did I first MRSA
bait oh my god
actually I remember I watched for the
first time Top Gun yeah I was so turned
on movie
so did you masturbate zoom you have to
watch the movie you haven't watched the
movie it's when Tom Cruise is about to
have sex with Kelly Kelly my feelings I
think it's in her name I watched a movie
like repeatedly so probably I was like
11 okay
when was my first kiss I think it was
like when I was like really little I was
like a toddler I was in a pool and I
almost drowned I got like all this water
in my mouth okay okay free space that's
me why you want who was your best sexual
partner including me
of course you how did I was my virginity
that's fun I remember specifically the
song that was playing because I only
wanted to have sex to this song at the
time I was dating my first like
relationship ever we had to get really
drunk cuz I didn't want to like I didn't
know what to do so I wanted to be really
drunk and we played that song and like
we've had it on repeat and then we went
up to the bedroom and then you kind of
plan that you were gonna have sex that
day I guess it wasn't a good experience
I think it was like it hurt and I was
drunk and I had a massive hangover the
next day Oh interesting
okay how many partners have I had
so I already know who that was my first
one
for 15 years I was home for a couple of
years and you for three years I'm glad I
didn't get that question when you're
glad you didn't got that question
because on our on and off stages in the
beginning you know what we weren't
together so what so what
you know what no I'm Mario kill me
that's not an answer
yeah how many what how many partners
have you had
three three there's one there's two and
no no next I'm going now okay am I in
love with you
yes okay are you sure
[Laughter]
I really like that I love it yeah three
partners hmm we'll talk about it after I
think that was more exciting than I
thought because I want something maybe
like it was the right time because you
always learn something new from your
partner so I'm glad I did it right now
no before I think other couples should
play this game because that's really
good
[Laughter]
[Music]